monsieur thomann bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors la
russie a pesé de tout son poids pour
arracher cette trêve fragile et elle
anticipé cette rave selon vous il faut
regardons la regardons la situation avec
une analyse clinique de la situation la
russie évidemment est le seul acteur qui
en mesure de peser sur ce conflit qui
menace de déstabiliser tout le caucase
il faut se rappeler aussi le contexte
géopolitique globale dans laquelle se
produit cette crise c'est à dire qu'il y
à un arc d'instabilité au tour de la
russie dans les trajets proche de la
russie c'est à dire aubier or
biélorussie avec le soutien à
l'opposition par l'otan et l'union
européenne
la sphère navalni qui a instrumentalisé
pour torpiller le projet nord stream 2
est aujourd'hui un nouveau front qui
s'ouvre dans le caucase avec la turquie
qui soutient l'azerbaïdjan acquis qui a
lancé une offensive au haut karabakh et
donc la russie qui est fait partie du
groupe de minsk est le seul acteur qui
soit en mesure d'apaiser les tensions et
ne peut pas prendre parti non plus pour
l'une ou l'autre partie pour se
préserver le rôle de médiateur là la
russie qui peut pas prendre parti car
elle a des intérêts avec justement les
deux pays que ce soit l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan
mais si aujourd'hui voilà on voit que
finalement ce cessez le feu ne parvient
pas à calmer la situation est ce que le
groupe de minsk
voilà peut faire autre chose qu elles
sont finalement les autres ressorts qui
sont en leur possession pour imposer
ou essayer en tout cas de trouver une
solution à cette crise si les
belligérants ne cesse pas de s'affronter
sur le terrain pour évidemment dans
leurs négociations pour avoir une être
en position de force l'un vis-à-vis de
l'autre il y a une une menace qui est en
train de da grave et la situation c'est
à dire l'arrivée de djihadistes une
internationale djihadistes qui arrive de
syrie et le cocasse pourrait devenir un
lieu d'attraction de cet international
djihadistes avec le soutien de la
turquie et avec une aggravation de la
situation
si le groupe de minsk eux n'arrive pas à
stabiliser la situation et si la russie
a du mal à peser sur les deux
belligérants pour arriver un
cessez-le-feu pour faire respecter le
cessez-le-feu
il y aura cet aspect qui risquent de
d'aggraver la situation et la russie
sera sans doute obligée d'intervenir
pour stopper l'afflux de djihadistes
internationaux il faut voir que le
contexte géopolitique de rivalité entre
turquie et russie ou la turquie et la
russie sont rivalité en syrie et la
russie a stoppé en fait la tentative de
changement de régime en syrie et ses
tentatives de changement de régime en
syrie était appuyée par l'arrivée de
djihadistes internationaux soutenus
notamment par la turquie et le cette
ouverture du nouveau front au conca au
caucase pourra être une revanche pour la
turquie
il ya aussi le rôle de l'otan et des
états unis qui est je pense faussement
présenté comme étant neutres ou retirés
du conflit je pense qu'il ya une
impunité vis-à-vis de la turquie et et
dans certains milieux atlantiste a même
un assentiment implicite
à cette offensive à turco azéri parce
que la turquie joue le rôle de
contrepoids à la russie dans le caucase
et en synergie avec les la
déstabilisation du pourtour de
l'étranger proche de la russie avec le
soutien à l'opposition aux embiez
biélorussie la sphère navalni et
l'ouverture de ce troisième front il ya
là là l'objectif de repousser la russie
dans ses terres continentales et les
états unis notamment on voit bien que
ils ont soutenu la turquie à une libre
pour empêcher une victoire totale de la
russie en syrie ils mettent des lignes
rouges à la turquie aussi par rapport à
la grèce et à chypre
mais dans le caucase c'est beaucoup plus
ambigu et il y a une volonté de
retourner la turquie contre la russie
parce qu'elle joue aussi un rôle ambigu
au sein de l'alliance de l'otan on parle
évidemment du groupe de minsk qui est
composé de paris washington et moscou
qui est censé être le médiateur sur le
sujet il ya d'autres acteurs dont on n'a
pas beaucoup entendu parler on sait que
l'union européenne par exemple redoutent
une internet internationalisation de ce
conflit
mais est ce qu'elle peut agir elle à son
tour
donc je pense que l'union européenne est
très divisé et en réalité eu la
diplomatie de l'union européenne est
souvent très proches de celles des états
unis et notamment les etats-unis l'otan
et l'union européenne craignent en
réalité une mise en danger de l'homme du
corridor énergétique sud parce qu'il ya
le gaz et le pétrole qui passe par
dessus relaxe azerbaïdjan géorgie
turquie est donc cet axe est une
alternative à l'importation de gaz et
pétrole russe et donc il y a aussi une
fausse neutralité
d'autre part il y à certains acteurs pro
turc e et compte qu'ils sont atlantis et
qui vise la russie qui aimerait bien
faire entrer la turquie dans les
négociations et qui considère le groupe
minsk comme obsolète pour que la turquie
joue le rôle de contrepoids la russie
mais évidemment je pense que le meilleur
que l'on puisse arriver c'est une
nouveau un conflit gelé dans le meilleur
des cas et à l'avenir il n'y aura pas de
solution sans une nouvelle architecture
européenne de sécurité qui avait été
proposé par la france d'ailleurs
tant qu'ils y arrivent alité entre
turquie russie et turquie et occident
notamment les états unis qui essaient de
repousser la thur la russie dans ses
terres continentales au moyen de la
déstabilisation de l'étranger proche
il n'y a pas d'espoir pour régler tous
ces conflits gelés dans l'ex urss
merci beaucoup pierre emmanuel thomas
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant
géopolitique et fondateur d'euro
continent